des manifestants s'étaient réunis au
centre-ville après l'intervention
télévisée d'Emmanuel Macron
Jean-Baptiste trogneux 29 ans rentrée à
son domicile situé juste au-dessus de la
chocolaterie familiale l'homme
âgé de 30 ans a été frappé à la tête au
bras et aux jambes en marge de ce
collage en France Presse s'appelle une
casserole mais jusqu'où va aller cet
escalade jusqu'où va aller cet escalade
on attend quoi on attend qu'il y a un
mort finalement
un niveau de
d'inépsie qui est insupportable pour ce
printemps
vous personnellement sur ce que fait ce
que dit votre oncle bien évidemment donc
on l'a on arrive à un niveau de bêtise
humaine invraisemblable et je vais le
dire sur le plateau de Laurence Ferrari
jusqu'où on va aller dans cette société
mais c'est pas possible la semaine
dernière c'était le maire de
Saint-Brévin à les pins aujourd'hui
c'est un membre de la famille du
président de la République Brigitte
Macron Macron l'épouse du président de
la République qui a confié à l'AFP
qu'elle dénonçait la lâcheté la bêtise
et la violence des agresseurs de son
petit neveu on est évidemment horrifié
terrifié rien ne justifie qu'on
s'entraîne ni aux élus ni à leur famille
et bah oui l'extrême gauche a quand même
mis un climat de violence et amis de
l'huile sur le feu bien évidemment c'est
une agression un qualifiable lâche vous
avez dit plusieurs personnes contre une
seule qui n'a pas sa place dans la
démocratie on ne règle pas ces
différents politiques par des violences
physiques sur des personnes on ne règle
pas ses comptes politiques en agressant
des gens et je condense cette agression
avec la plus grande fermeté jour il y a
le collaborateur d'une de députés qui a
été passée à tabac comme ça autour du
stade de France par des gens d'extrême
droite de la même manière j'aurais
prouve ce genre d'action mais il y a
toujours un mais avec la France
insoumise et ça c'est intolérable parce
que ça c'est vraiment c'est c'est
quelque part cautionner un acte on y
trouvant une cause il y a pas à
cautionner quoi que ce soit la violence
n'a pas place en démocratie quelle
qu'elle soit et en particulier dans la
nôtre il a été confronté à la brutalité
à la violence à la bêtise et avec
beaucoup de courage ce jeune papa s'est
interposé pour protéger sa boutique je
souhaite avoir une pensée émue et
exprimer un soutien que j'espère unanime
dans notre assemblée pour Yannick Moret
mère de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins alors
Atlantique
la façade de ma maison a été
couverte d'autocollants d'Éric Zemmour
et donc je savais que les partisans
d'Éric Zemmour savaient où j'habitais
alors que j'avais une fille de 17 ans
seul à la maison à ce moment-là oui
c'est très très désagréable le groupe
démocrate est choqué que certains soient
restés assis nous sommes scandalisés
levons-nous quand on voit la médiocrité
de certains élus qui prennent la parole
on n'est pas étonné on n'est pas étonné
avec des cas comme ça mais mais plus
personne ne veut s'engager et se dire
mais étant je vais aller m'engager pour
que ma famille soit en danger la
première ministre quant à elle reçoit
les syndicats aujourd'hui et demain
premier à ouvrir le bal Frédéric
Souillot de Force Ouvrière à 18h15 suivi
de Laurent Berger pour la CFDT à 19h30
donc ce qu'on va dire à la première
ministre c'est d'abord on va lui parler
des retraites en disant qu'il y a un
nouveau rendez-vous à l'Assemblée
nationale le 8 et qu'il faut laisser
faire sa position
voilà et et on va lui dire il faut aussi
réparer ce que vous avez un peu abîmé
demain ce sera autour de François
homeril pour la CFE-CGC Cyril Chabanier
pour la CFTC puis enfin Sophie Binet
pour la CGT c'est le dialogue n'a en
réalité jamais été rompu avec les
syndicats nous nous réjouissons qu'il
marque une nouvelle étape formelle
celle-ci pour faire avancer concrètement
les droits des salariés qu'est-ce qui
fait que vous croyez à l'innocence de
Tariq Ramadan monsieur Dieudonné
qu'est-ce qui fait que vous n'y croyez
pas si vous me donnez des arguments à un
argument de passant je vous en donnant
un c'était une journée en mer assez
banale pour ce pêcheur quand soudain
[Musique]
une attaque de requin-tigre au large de
l'île d'eau à eau dans l'archipel
d'Hawaï